Many Americans feel they are embattled in a culture war that is not only dividing them, but stressing them out. An American Psychological Association survey showed that 52% of American adults report that the 2016 election is a significant source of stress. This type of stress could be largely related to people's differing views on what is fact and what is moral. In this episode, we speak with a psychologist about how scientific research into how people feel, think and behave can help us understand how we became so divided and how we can come back together. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Jonathan Haidt is a social psychologist at New York University's Stern School of Business. His research has focused on the moral foundations of politics and on ways to transcend the
许多美国人觉得他们正陷入一场文化战争中，这不仅让他们产生分裂，还给他们带来了巨大压力。美国心理学协会的一项调查显示，52%的美国成年人表示，2016年大选是他们压力的一个重要来源。这种压力在很大程度上可能与人们对什么是事实、什么是道德持有不同观点有关。在本期节目中，我们邀请了一位心理学家，探讨关于人类情感、思考和行为的科学研究如何能帮助我们理解我们是如何变得如此分裂的，以及我们如何才能重新走到一起。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是“心理学话语”。乔纳森·海特是纽约大学斯特恩商学院的社会心理学家。他的研究重点是政治的道德基础，以及如何超越
culture wars by using recent discoveries in moral psychology to foster more civil forms of politics. He is the author of the Happiness Hypothesis and of the New York Times bestseller, The Righteous Mind, Why Good People Are Divided by Politics and Religion. Welcome, Dr. Hype. Thank you, Audrey. Pleasure to be here. Cefility in politics. That sounds like a pipe dream, especially in a presidential election year. What do you mean by a civil form of politics? People are very good at relating to each other in different ways. We're extremely good at adversarial forms, at attacking each other at being lawyers, at fighting. And we're also really good at cooperating and
文化战争，利用道德心理学的新发现来促进更文明的政治形式。他是《幸福假说》以及《纽约时报》畅销书《正义之心：为什么好人总是因政治和宗教而分裂》的作者。欢迎您，海特博士。谢谢你，奥黛丽。很高兴来到这里。政治中的文明。听起来这就像是个不切实际的幻想，尤其是在总统大选之年。你所说的文明的政治形式是什么意思？人们非常擅长以不同的方式相互交往。我们极擅长对抗性的形式，擅长互相攻击，像律师一样，擅长争斗。但我们也同样擅长合作、
working together or courting each other. So we can easily shift back and forth into different modes. I co-run a group called civilpolitics.org where we're trying to promote civil political talk. And here's what we say at the site. We say civility as we pursue it is the ability to disagree productively with others, respecting the their sincerity and decency. And that's the key, is the sincerity and decency thing. When you're talking with people and you're arguing or disagreeing with them, that's fine, that's great.
共同工作或追求彼此。所以我们可以轻松地在不同的模式之间切换。我共同运营一个名为civilpolitics.org的组织，我们在其中努力推动文明的政治对话。以下是我们在该网站上的表述：我们所追求的文明，是能够与他人进行富有成效的分歧探讨，同时尊重他们的真诚与正派。这才是关键所在，也就是真诚和正派。当你与人交谈、争论或有分歧时，这很好，这很棒。
That's what politics is supposed to be. But when what you're saying is aimed at discrediting their sincerity or decency, not rebutting their arguments, but saying, yeah, you're just saying that because you're bribed by the Koch brothers or, you know, you're a fascist, you're a racist. Those aren't real arguments. Those are attempts to discredit the other. So that's the more adversarial confrontational zero sum, or you might even say negative some. The more I can hurt you, the better I am.
这本该就是政治应有的样子。但如果你的言论旨在诋毁他们的真诚或正直，而不是反驳他们的论点，而是说，是的，你这么说只是因为你被科赫兄弟收买了，或者你知道的，你是个法西斯分子，你是个种族主义者。这些不是真正的论据。这些是试图抹黑对方的行为。所以这更具对抗性、对立性、零和博弈，甚至可以说是负和博弈。我能多伤害你一点，对我就越有利。
And that's what our politics has descended more into than it used to be. Well, it does seem like the divisiveness has reached a point where there's no turning back. I mean, you're saying that psychology and other social sciences can help us understand where we are, how we got here and how to change. Can you talk to us about that? Well, sure, because there's no such thing as no turning back. I mean, things are really, really bad. I think the days of the federalists and anti-federalists and, you know, the founding fathers, even Thomas Jefferson and others were making up pen names and so they could attack each other anonymously, you know, like being trolls on the Internet almost.
而我们的政治比过去更多地演变成这样。嗯，这种分裂似乎已经到了无法回头的地步。我的意思是，你认为心理学和其他社会科学可以帮助我们理解我们身处何地、我们是如何走到这一步的以及如何改变。你能和我们谈谈这个吗？当然可以，因为根本没有“无法回头”这回事。我的意思是，事情确实非常非常糟糕。我认为联邦党人和反联邦党人那个时代的那些国父们，甚至托马斯·杰斐逊和其他人，当时都在使用笔名，以便可以匿名攻击对方，你知道的，几乎就像网上的喷子一样。
And the Civil War was, of course, much worse than things are today. So things do go in cycles. Now things are at a low point. They've not been this bad, I think, since the late 19th century. So there is turning back, but it's going to be tough. There are a lot of trends that are pushing us this way now. What role does the popularity of social media, you know, Facebook, 24-hour news channels, constantly putting up pundits to say this and you say that, you know,
而且内战当然比现在糟糕得多。所以事情确实是呈周期性发展的。现在事情处于低谷。我认为，自19世纪末以来，情况还从未如此糟糕过。所以还是可以回头的，但这将会很艰难。现在有许多趋势正将我们推向这个方向。社交媒体的普及——你知道的，Facebook、24小时新闻频道，不断安排专家说这个说那个——
what do they play in this divisiveness? Sam Abrams, who's a political scientist, he and I wrote an essay in the Washington Post last year in which we described the 10 major trends that have, made our politics so polarized and dysfunctional. The number one is the purification of the parties. So we didn't used to have a clear conservative party and a clear progressive party. There was a left and right wing of both parties
它们在这个分裂过程中扮演了什么角色？萨姆·艾布拉姆斯是一位政治学家，我和他去年在《华盛顿邮报》上合写了一篇文章，我们在文中描述了导致我们的政治如此极化和功能失调的十大主要趋势。首要的一点就是政党的纯净化。所以我们过去没有一个清晰的保守党和一个清晰的进步党。两个党派内部都有左翼和右翼之分，
up until really until the 1970s. But once after President Johnson signed the Civil Rights Act, and that made the conservative Democrats, in the South especially, leave the Democratic Party, joined the Republican Party. In 1964. In 1964, that's right. So that starts these tectonic plates shifting, which gives us a purified, liberal, progressive party and a purified conservative party.
实际上一直持续到20世纪70年代。但在约翰逊总统签署《民权法案》之后，这使得南方的保守派民主党人尤其离开了民主党，加入了共和党。在1964年。在1964年，没错。所以这拉开了这些板块移动的序幕，从而给我们带来了一个纯净的自由主义进步党和一个纯净的保守党。
And so that really begins to take shape in the 1980s, and by the 90s, it's complete. All right, so you asked me about social media. Well, this is the backstory to it. Once you have these purified parties, and that happens at the same time as this media revolution, where you got cable TV and then the Internet, so that now the media that people, consume is is all confirmatory. Everybody can tune into things that support their worldview. So those two trends interact to give us this perfect storm where everyone is now totally convinced, not just that they're right, but that the other side is racist or fascist or funded by the coax or PC, whatever
所以这在20世纪80年代真正开始成形，到90年代就已经完成了。好的，所以你问我关于社交媒体的问题。这就是它的背景故事。一旦你有了这些纯净的政党，而这又与媒体革命同时发生——你拥有了有线电视和互联网，因此现在人们消费的媒体全都是相互印证的。每个人都可以收听那些支持他们世界观的内容。因此，这两种趋势相互作用，形成了一场完美的风暴，现在每个人都完全坚信，不仅自己是正确的，而且另一方是种族主义者、法西斯主义者、由科赫兄弟资助的，或者是政治正确的，无论是什么
it is. So yeah, it's real bad. I was talking with somebody at the APA convention about this the other day, and we kind of worked up the metaphor. It's like, you know, it's like if you go back, social media to me is like this technology that we're just not adapted for you. We're not used to yet. So it's like imagine if you go back 50,000 years and humans are just leaving Africa. And we have spear technology. We've had spears for about a half million years. We kind of know how to kill each other with spears, but we also know how to get along
反正就是这样。所以，情况真的很糟糕。前几天我在APA（美国心理学协会）大会上和某人谈起过这件事，我们琢磨出了一个隐喻。这就像是，你知道的，这就像是回溯过去，在我看来，社交媒体就像是一种我们根本没有适应的技术，我们还不习惯它。所以这就好比想象一下，如果回到5万年前，人类刚刚离开非洲。我们拥有长矛技术。我们使用长矛大约有五十万年了。我们多少知道如何用长矛杀死对方，但我们也知道如何相处，
when there's all these spears around. So we've been living with spears for half a million years. But suddenly some malevolent. other species from another planet drops loaded handguns all over the world so that you get this, the Speer Technology people, and they suddenly, everybody's got loaded handguns. Like, what? What are these things?
当周围有这么多长矛的时候。所以我们与长矛共存了五十万年。但突然间，来自另一个星球的某个充满恶意的物种在全世界各地投放了上膛的手枪，于是你就会发现，原本使用长矛技术的人们，突然每个人手里都有了上膛的手枪。就像是：什么？这些东西是什么？
He pulled the trigger, the other guy's dead. Wow, this is great. There'd be a lot of killing. Eventually, we presume, they'd work out norms for how to live with handguns, but it would take a while. That's where we are with social media. We all really care about reputations,
他扣动了扳机，另一个人就死了。哇，这太棒了。这会引发大量的杀戮。最终，我们推测，他们会摸索出如何与手枪共存的规范，但这需要一段时间。这就是我们在社交媒体上面临的处境。我们所有人都非常在意名誉，
and we suddenly have this technology that allows us to slander anyone else instantly to draw a mob. So what's happened is people are really, really afraid. I see this on college campuses. People are so afraid to stand up, stand out, say anything unless it's with the mob. If the mob is on their side, then they are so vocal and self-righteous. But what I'm finding is that even moderists are centrist, people are not political, are afraid to speak up and challenge the left. they'll get crucified.
而我们突然拥有了这样一项技术，它允许我们瞬间诽谤任何人、煽动暴民。所以发生的情况是，人们真的、真的感到害怕。我在大学校园里看到了这一点。人们非常害怕挺身而出、脱颖而出、发表任何言论，除非是与暴民保持一致。如果暴民站在他们这一边，那么他们就会表现得非常高调和自以为是。但我发现的是，即使是温和派或中间派、不问政治的人，也害怕发声并挑战左翼。他们会被钉上十字架。
Right. An Associated Press poll last year found that Republican voters want their congressional leaders to stick to conservative principles while Democrats favor compromise. And there are many more differences between the two parties. Your expertise is in moral psychology, which is kind of a broad term encompassing ethic, psychology, and philosophy. Can you talk about how psychology can help us explain these differences? Oh, sure.
没错。美联社去年的一项民意调查发现，共和党选民希望他们的国会领袖坚持保守原则，而民主党人则赞成妥协。两党之间还有更多差异。你的专业领域是道德心理学，这是一个包罗伦理学、心理学和哲学的广义词汇。你能谈谈心理学如何帮助我们解释这些差异吗？哦，当然可以。
It's been a major area of research for a lot of people. there are a lot of, well, if you want to understand left-right differences, some of it is true asymmetries. That is, people on the left psychologically are different from people on the right. And the most consistent differences are that people on the left are higher on openness to experience. They enjoy variety and diversity. And then also they're a little lower on conscientiousness. So you put this all together, and what you get is people on the left, are more interested in immigration, diversity, variety.
这一直是许多人研究的主要领域。有很多，嗯，如果你想了解左右翼之间的差异，其中一部分是真正的非对称性。也就是说，心理学上左翼人士与右翼人士是不同的。最一致的差异是，左翼人士在对经验的开放性上得分更高。他们喜欢多样性和多元化。而且他们在尽责性上也稍低一些。所以你把这些结合在一起，你会发现左翼人士，对移民、多样性、多元化更感兴趣。
Research by Sam Gosling at UT Austin shows that if you look at the dorm rooms of people, he did this study at Berkeley, you go into people's dorm rooms when they're not there. They give you permission to go in. You just take photographs. You code things. And then you show those to other students to just rate, do you think this person is liberal or conservative? People can tell. Liberals are less organized.
得克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的萨姆·戈斯林的研究表明，如果你看看人们的宿舍，他在伯克利做过这项研究，当人们不在时，你走进他们的宿舍。他们允许你进去。你只需拍照片。你对物品进行编码。然后你把这些照片展示给其他学生让他们进行评定：你认为这个人是自由派还是保守派？人们能分辨出来。自由派的组织性较差。
They have more high style. They have fewer calendars. Conservatives are more organized, responsible. Their music and books are from a narrower range. So there are psychological differences. Neither one is good or bad, but it does help explain why they differ on issues of immigration, nationalism, patriotism, all those sorts of things.
他们的时尚感更强。他们的日历更少。保守派更有组织性、更有责任感。他们的音乐和书籍范围较窄。所以确实存在心理差异。没有哪一个好或坏，但这确实有助于解释为什么他们在移民、民族主义、爱国主义等问题上存在分歧。
So you start with those, and that means that people who are born with a certain personality, as they grow up, they're going to find right-wing or left-wing ideas more congenial. Our genes don't predestine us to be on one side, but they make one side or the other more likely. So there's a lot of interesting research on personality and politics. Then the next thing you have to bring in is group dynamics. So you get these two groups fighting it out, and your question was about issues of compromise. Well, yes, it's true that right now the word compromise is a dirty word for Republicans.
所以你从这些开始，这意味着那些生来带有特定个性的人，在他们长大后，会发现右翼或左翼的思想更合他们的心意。我们的基因并没有预先注定我们必须站在哪一边，但它们让某一边或另一边变得更有可能。因此，关于个性和政治，有很多有趣的研究。接下来你必须引入的是群体动力学。所以你会看到这两群人争斗不休，而你的问题是关于妥协的问题。嗯，是的，确实现在“妥协”这个词对共和党人来说是个脏话。
And there was some funny episodes, you know, five years ago. A lot of us remember when I forget which journalist was trying to get John Boehner to say the word compromise. And he wouldn't say it because he knows that if he in any way endorsed compromise, his people would consider him a traitor. So is it that the right is more closed-minded and against compromise? It depends a lot on which side feels more embattled, which side feels it's being crushed, which side? is more self-righteous. And so that can shift. That can go back and forth.
五年前有一些滑稽的插曲。我们很多人都记得，我忘了是哪个记者试图让约翰·博纳说出“妥协”这个词。他就是不肯说，因为他知道，如果他以任何方式支持妥协，他的人民就会认为他是叛徒。那么，是否右翼更加思想封闭且反对妥协？这很大程度上取决于哪一方感到更受围困、哪一方感到自己正在被压迫、哪一方
There is also the interesting difference that in studies of like trolley dilemmas of, you know, would you push a man off a bridge, one man to save the lives of five, there's some research showing that conservatives are more deontological. That means they go more with absolute rules and principles. Like, no, you don't kill someone. You don't push someone off a bridge. So it is possible that people in the right are. more principled in the sense of these are the rules. You don't break them. Whereas people on the
更加自以为是。所以这种情况是可以转变的。这是可以来回变化的。还有一个有趣的差异，即在诸如电车难题的研究中——比如你是否会把一个人推下桥去拯救五个人的生命——有一些研究表明，保守派更具道义论倾向。这意味着他们更倾向于绝对的规则和原则。比如，不，你不能杀人。你不能把人推下桥。所以右翼人士可能
left are more like, well, you know, you've got to look at the outcomes, do all these tradeoffs. So in that case, I don't know for sure whether it's truly that the right is more opposed to compromise. You have to look at all these different factors. So how can we use psychology to reduce the intensity of these conflicts? I mean, like you say, we're always going to have them. There's always going to be some differences in conflict between, but how do we reduce the intensity of it. Yeah, well, this is where social psychology can be so helpful. Because one of the great, one of the great psychological aphorisms or quotations, there's a Bedouin proverb that says, me against my brother, me and my brother against our cousin,
更具有原则性，这里的原则是指这些是规则。你不能打破它们。而左翼人士则更像是，嗯，你知道的，你必须看结果，去做所有这些权衡。所以在那种情况下，我无法确定右翼是否真的更反对妥协。你必须审视所有这些不同的因素。那么我们如何利用心理学来降低这些冲突的烈度呢？我的意思是，就像你说的，我们总是会有这些冲突。总会存在一些分歧和冲突，但我们该如何降低它的烈度呢？是的，好，这就是社会心理学大显身手的地方。因为最伟大、最了不起的心理学格言或名言之一，有一句贝都因人的谚语说：我与我的兄弟，我和兄弟联手对抗堂兄弟，
and me, my brother and cousin against the stranger. So we're tribal. We're tribal creatures. And it used to be in American politics, that they would say politics, ends at the water's edge. Sure, we can fight it out, you know, Democrat, Republican, but as soon as as there's a foreign policy issue, we stopped that and we're united. And that was the case when I was a kid. You heard that a lot. But beginning of the 90s, that stopped being the case. Now it's basically me and my brother against our cousin, and we don't care what else is happening. We just hate the cousin, and a matter who we're being attacked by, we're going to focus on fighting the cousin. So our partisanship is kind of stuck. But there's a lot you can do to move things around.
然后是我、兄弟和堂兄弟一起对抗外人。所以我们是部落化的。我们是部落动物。在过去的美国政治中，人们会说政治在水边结束。当然，我们可以争论，民主党、共和党，但一旦出现外交政策问题，我们就停止争端并团结一致。我在孩提时代就是这样的。你经常听到这种说法。但从90年代初开始，情况不再是这样了。现在基本上是我和兄弟对抗堂兄弟，我们不在乎其他事情发生了什么。我们只恨堂兄弟，无论谁在攻击我们，我们都会专注于对付堂兄弟。所以我们的党派偏见有点陷入了僵局。但你可以做很多事情来扭转局面。
because in addition to being tribal, humans are also really cooperative and we're really good at trade. Our ancestors were really good at leaving their tribe and going out and finding other groups to exchange with. So there's a lot of hope. One of the most consistent findings in social psychology is that when you give groups a superordinate threat or goal, some project to work on together, they tend to drop the tribalism and work together. I was very fortunate to be involved with a group. I was able to moderate a group of poverty experts, some of the top experts on the right and left, on poverty.
因为除了部落化之外，人类其实也非常合作，我们非常擅长交易。我们的祖先非常擅长离开自己的部落，出去寻找其他群体进行交换。所以有很多希望。社会心理学中最一致的发现之一是：当赋予群体一个超越性的威胁或目标、某个需要共同完成的项目时，他们往往会抛弃部落主义并共同合作。我很荣幸能参与一个小组。我曾主持一个由贫困专家组成的小组，其中一些是左右翼顶尖的贫困问题专家。
And in our first few meetings, we worked for about a year in 2015. We worked for a year together. And our first few meetings was really clear. There was the left team and the right team. And the left team was really focused on economic causes of poverty and structural problems and racism. And the right was really focused on family breakdown and the need for order and discipline
在我们的前几次会议中，我们在2015年一起工作了大约一年。我们一起工作了一年。在前几次会议中，情况非常明朗。有左翼团队和右翼团队。左翼团队真正专注于贫困的经济根源、结构性问题和种族主义，而右翼则真正专注于家庭解体以及对秩序、纪律、
and self-control and delay of gratification. And at first it was really clear, well, you know, actually both sides are actually right, and we just have to figure out a way that we can incorporate all of their insights into the final report. And what was most thrilling was that by the end of this year-long process, there wasn't a right team or a left team anymore. And one of our last meetings,
自我控制和延迟满足的需求。起初，情况非常明朗，嗯，你知道的，实际上双方都是对的，我们只需要找出一种方法，将他们所有的见解都纳入最后的报告中。最让人激动的是，到这一年过程结束时，不再有什么右翼团队或左翼团队了。在我们最后的几次会议之一中，
I gave the groups the option of caucusing separately because we had these final recommendations and, okay, do you guys need to talk separately to be sure you endorse these. And they all said, no, no, we don't, we don't, we don't, no, you know, let's talk about it all together. They really had a sense of, we've been working on this thing for a year, we've come so far, we have a great set of recommendations. So it can take some time. But if you foster relationships in a sense of common or shared group identity with a common goal or project, you can break down the tribalism. Switching gears a little bit to the field of psychology. What have you learned about the political leanings of psychologists themselves? and how does that affect the field's viewpoint on politically controversial topics? Oh my. Well,
我给各个小组提供了分开开会的选项，因为我们有这些最后的建议，“好吧，你们需要分开讨论以确保你们支持这些建议吗？”他们都说：“不，不，不，不，不用，你知道的，让我们一起讨论吧。”他们确实有一种感觉：我们已经在这个项目上工作了一年，我们已经取得了如此巨大的进展，我们有一套很棒的建议。所以这确实需要一些时间。但如果你在共同的目标或项目下培养关系和共同或共享的群体认同感，你就能打破部落主义。稍微转换一下话题，谈谈心理学领域。关于心理学家自身的政治倾向，你了解到了什么？这又如何影响该领域对政治争议话题的观点呢？天哪。好吧，
so, you know, what's been happening to our country since the 90s or so is that it's almost like a gigantic electromagnet with a positive pole and a negative pole pulling us apart. And we're seeing whole, you know, we're seeing religious denominations splitting over this into the, you know, the more left-wing Episcopalians and the right-wing Episcopalians. And that's been happening in universities. Universities have leaned left for more than 100 years. And that's not really a problem in my view. We don't have to have 50-50 parity and everything. What we must have in the science is we must have the certainty that ideas will be critiqued. So if somebody says something that's, you know, very sort of left, we don't pleases the left. It's got to be the case that someone will
所以，你知道的，自90年代左右以来，我们的国家发生的事情就像是一个巨大的电磁铁，有着正极和负极将我们拉开。我们看到整个，你知道的，我们看到宗教教派因此分裂为更偏左的圣公会教徒和右翼的圣公会教徒。大学里也发生了这种情况。大学向左倾斜已经超过100年了。在我看来，这其实并不是什么问题。我们不需要在每件事上都达到50对50的对等。我们在科学中必须做到的是：我们必须确信观点会被批判。所以如果有人说了某种，你知道的，非常偏左的话，迎合了左翼，那必须得有人
stand up and say, well, wait a second, you're making this assumption. You know, somebody has to be there to say that. And so until the 90s, there were some people around who are not on the left. But what's happened in psychology and in the social sciences more broadly, and it happened especially in the humanities, is they shifted from being on the left or leaning left, two or three to one, to leaning left, 10 to 1, 20 to 1, on some measures 30 or 40 to 1, which means that you will never find someone who's not on the left. Or rather, there are a few, but they don't dare speak up. Even the Centrists, what I find is that even in surveys, even people who say, I'm not on the right, I'm in the middle.
站出来说：“等一下，你做出了这个假设。”你知道的，必须有人在那里说出这句话。所以在90年代之前，周围还有一些并非左翼的人士。但心理学和社会科学更广泛地发生了什么，尤其是在人文学科中，它们从原本左倾或偏左（比例为2比1或3比1），变成了偏左10比1、20比1，在某些衡量标准下甚至是30比1或40比1，这意味着你永远不会找到一个不属于左翼的人。或者更准确地说，有一些人，但他们不敢发声。甚至连中间派也是如此，我发现即使在民意调查中，甚至那些说“我不是右翼，我在中间”的人，
Are you willing to speak up and challenge things if they're politically controversial? No, no, it's just too dangerous. So the social sciences, I think, are breaking down, not entirely, but on politicized topics. If we're talking about race, gender, immigration, inequality, whatever the favorite topics are, I think the research coming out is just not, well, individual research projects can be very good, but the overall output is really tilted, and a lot of ideas are there because they're politically pleasing, not because they're empirically supported.
你愿意在遇到政治争议时发声并提出挑战吗？不，不，这太危险了。所以我认为社会科学正在崩溃，虽然不是全部，但在政治化的话题上确实如此。如果我们讨论种族、性别、移民、不平等，无论这些最热门的话题是什么，我认为产出的研究确实……嗯，个人的研究项目可能非常好，但整体成果严重倾斜，许多观点之所以存在，是因为它们迎合了政治需求，而不是因为它们得到了实证支持。
It's a huge problem. And that's why I started a group with some friends of mine called heterodox academy.org. I urge listeners to go check it out. We make the case that the academy needs more viewpoint diversity. Diversity is a good thing. But the most important kind of diversity is viewpoint diversity. You have to have people who actually think differently,
这是一个巨大的问题。这就是为什么我和我的几个朋友创立了一个名为heterodox academy.org（异见学院）的组织。我敦促听众去看看。我们提出，学术界需要更多的观点多样性。多样性是一件好事。但最重要的多样性是观点多样性。你必须有那些真正思考方式不同的人，
just to have people who are a different race or sex doesn't help your thinking unless they think differently. And we've been so focused on those demographic diversity things that it's actually made the viewpoint diversity issue even harder. Because when everyone's focused on race and gender diversity, then they're almost all on the left, and they see conservatives as the enemy, as they're racist and sexes. We don't want them here. And this is what's happened in psychology as in the other social sciences. All right, well, Dr. Haid, thank you so much for joining us. I appreciate your time. It's been great. My pleasure, Audrey. Thanks for listening. If you would like more information on the topics we discussed, or if you would like to hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
仅仅拥有不同种族或性别的人对你的思考并没有帮助，除非他们的思维方式也不同。我们过去太专注于那些人口统计学上的多样性，以至于这实际上让观点多样性的问题变得更加困难。因为当每个人都专注于种族和性别多样性时，他们几乎全都在左翼，并且把保守派视为敌人，认为他们是种族主义者和性别歧视者。我们不希望他们在这里。这就是心理学和其他社会科学所发生的事情。好了，海特博士，非常感谢您加入我们。我很感激您的时间。这太棒了。我的荣幸，奥黛丽。谢谢收听。如果您想要了解更多关于我们讨论话题的信息，或者如果您想收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学协会“心理学话语”栏目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。